italy was one of the first countries to
suffer
heavily from the pandemic one year ago
but it has since come a long way
after an intense lockdown period this
is rome now with packed streets as life
slowly
returns to normal but there is still
trauma and grief
nearly 96 thousand italians have lost
their lives
chris livesay reports from the hard-hit
northern part
of the country
it used to be that when my kids coughed
we didn't immediately freak out
says her mother marta zaninoni but now
in our family a cough
is no longer just a cough it's really
stressful
two weeks after beatrice was born her
mom noticed a fever
it was kovit the first case in a newborn
she says
they immediately put her in an incubator
i couldn't even say goodbye
beatrice became a symbol of hope for
hard-hit
bergamo as people followed her progress
in the hospital
the entire country would soon join
beatrice in isolation
then into what was for a free society
unthinkable
lockdown the death toll soared turning
the military
into morticians the disease not just
robbing people's lives
but also their dignity as well as city
streets of their people
but today from milan to rome
life is returning across italy old
traditions
are back but a little different you know
a year ago something as simple as
ordering a cappuccino would have been
unthinkable but it's hardly as if things
have gone back to normal
you still have to wear a mask at all
times even when you're outdoors
according to the law
except of course when you're eating or
drinking
a slow recovery not without casualties
something knows first hand kovid killed
her
uncle and grandfather while beatrice was
still in the hospital
finally after 40 days beatrice became
covet-free on easter day
says her mother it was a true
resurrection for us
despite all the death in italy beatrice
brought us life
a year later and italians are now
eagerly awaiting the vaccine which is
taking longer to roll out here in the
european union
than it is in the united states in fact
there are many italians
in their 80s who still have no idea when
they're going to get it this
in a country with one of the oldest
populations in the world
for cbs this morning chris livesay milan
looks pretty good over there in italy
you know an
too i italian like just to be somewhere
with somebody sitting next to you looks
really really good to me
and a cute baby christmas beatrice yes